do you ever get anything wrong i get  everything wrong it's just that i can't  recall it because once it's wrong i'm  moving on to the next thing  dwelling on what you [ __ ] up on is the  quickest way for the next thing not to  work  i was a breakout youtube star in the  first year 2006.  i decided that the right strategy was to  leave youtube completely  and go to viddler because viddler  offered me equity in their company  i deviated from my intention thesis to  do short-term economic and i lost  when drock finally came in my life two  years ago we started to try to build up  my youtube for the first time  i was sitting on 40 000 user followers  in a world where i could have had  millions if i just stayed the course  so i make mistakes all the time i'm  reorganizing vaynermedia every day  because it's based on a mistake i made  the prior year  i just don't give a [ __ ] about my  mistakes if you're worried about your  own mistakes you've already lost